how's it going reject nation greg here
welcome to part five of
our reaction to zack snyder's justice
league
if you guys can go ahead hit that like
button click subscribe hit that
notification bell to get notified
when our next reaction is up which
should be the final part that will be
swell our full-length uncut movie
reaction watch along where you sync up
with the time code that is over at our
patreon page thank you to
everyone who has joined our patreon just
this past week alone
it really means a lot considering how
challenging it is to get just these
individual parts up on youtube this week
and lastly gotta thank eric over at nerd
chronic for editing down the reaction
highlights here for youtube you've been
doing a great job buddy thank you so
much give them a follow today
anyhoo enjoy the reaction peeps
[Music]
exhume superman from the grave
check take him back from the darkness
not without giving one up in return
no we said it first prove it
[Laughter]
you did it you put the team together to
fight this war
you've fulfilled your promise now take a
break
your guilt overcome your reason how do
you know your team's strong enough
if you can't bring down the charging
bull then don't wave the red cape at it
you do what it's this red
cape this red cape charges back
man let's get the bat fleck first going
okay i love how the music is just like
that
to talk about visual storytelling
there's like auditory musical
storytelling happening in this movie too
you know
yeah it's optional
[Laughter]
thumbnails
the music in this is so good
[Music]
this feels like i feel like nolan the
producer
first time in oh yeah yeah it really
does too
i feel like the producer of christopher
nolan here clear this place uh
what the i just got out of current
[Music]
silas come on man
i can never go back to the other cut
i could never like never never ever
ever ever ever like burn the copies
it's crazy someone has hacked into the
system we must alert
that's my son doing it i was and i love
you nod
like it's an actual mission to get to
the krytonian ship you know like god
damn
part of me was like it'd be kind of
fascinating to then go back
and look at the other cut again and just
see but nah like
i kind of never want to ever watch that
again
a pregnancy testing i love that it's
called force major
like yeah superman's babies
oh oh
the hell with that photo yeah i'm gonna
let it clearly fit in the body
[Laughter]
all right i'm finally moving on fresh
start let's go back to the planet
i might be able to jump started i don't
like to break this rule but when i
approach the speed of light i i can
conduct a significant electrical current
i i might be able to wake the box if
that's still what we want
it is do it do it now i didn't think you
were coming
last time
oh and there's like real meaning to
showing back up here too
barry i'm initiating the countdown
[Music]
boom
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
oh
oh [ __ ] oh funeral pyre
dude
oh
[Music]
boiling water
[Music]
at bvs sequence yeah
oh
the slowest moe
god
oh
[Music]
his mouth looks good i know
mustache gate even gets fixed
all right now arthur you take your shirt
off
oh
oh no
i'm gonna crush you with my own head
oh
remember who you are
tell me who you are
no
where are you going so interesting to
see this like recontextualized yeah
wow
no ah oh
no that's not
gonna help
didn't kill anyone right
you should probably move
i got this guys i'm pretty confident i
can take
oh no
oh [ __ ]
no matter what they do
it's like they're all sharper like
batman
being rich will not help here oh this is
where batman gets this one f-bomb
i'm [ __ ]
no
oh that's right
[Music]
tell me lois deeply
you will
i'm so sorry
it was just fun man superman threw him
into you
i'm so sorry
uh silas it's busy repairing silas's
jacket
oh boy
oh god
damn wow behemoth
[Music]
what a nightmare
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my father i didn't save him
oh i couldn't his father's dead because
of us
i told you waking that box was a bad
idea it wasn't a bad idea
he recognized little slain who the woman
he loves
he went to her because she wasn't afraid
of him it's called instinct diana
he wasn't trying to destroy the box he
was he was trying to superheat it
we have to get back to my lab and use
the satellite to scan the earth to
thermal anomalies
i'm already on it yes you have a
satellite
i have sex do they all look like bats
battle lights all right people that's
the end of part five to our reaction to
zack snyder's justice league
part six should be up soon if it is
already up depending on what time in
in real rejects history you are watching
this there should be a card above me
should be the end screen that appears
after i'm done talking it should be in
the pinned comment or description box
if it's not there well then subscribe
and click that notification bell to get
notified
when our zack snyder's justice league
part six finale reactions you know where
i'm going this you know what i'm
plugging
you know i'm about to end this video